As a special surprise
moderating our panel today are two gentlemen you just saw in that video.
Supernatural's very own Chuck Shurley and The Trickster
aka Gabriel
You may also know them as the Kings of Con
Ladies and gentlemen, a very warm comic-con welcome
for Mr. Rob Benedict and Mr. Richard Speight Jr.
*Fans screaming like their heads are being chopped off*
RS: YEAH ROB
RB:  This is a big stag, Rich!
Both: Big stage small guys x4
RS: Wow there's a few people here
*Fans cheer*
RB: Hey, quick show of hands; How many of you are supernatural fans?
RB: What a coincidence!
RS: Nobody? Really weird
RS: Um, Robbie
RB: Hi! Yeah?
RS: How awesome is this?
RB: Fantastically awesome
RS: You know what's even more awesome?
RB: What?
RS: The people we're about to bring on this stage
RB: Heck yeah!
RS: I say we dive right into it. Shall we?
RB: Let's do it
RS: Cause the first guy I'm going to bring out
RS: May be the most important guy I'm going to introduce all day
RB: Yeah
RS: Really and truly. I mean he is the pointy end of the Supernatural bayonet
He crafts the stories, he builds the arcs, AND
He happens to have sole power over deciding which Supernatural fan-favorite characters
return to the show
RB: He's just a fantastic person
RS: Yeah he's a great great man
RB: It's just that we really kinda worship him
RS: Yeah, he's a bit of a god to us
RS: Handsome, painfully handsome. I don't know if he has a wife
I don't know if he has kids but, he's the best damn husband and father I've ever seen
RB: When this man passes wind, butterflies imerge from his buttom
RS: That may be a tad too far
RS: Ladies and gentlemen, please put your hands together for executive producer, show runner
JEREMY CARVER!
*cheering fan noises*
RS: That guy
RS: So here he is
RB: Hi Jemery!
JC: Hi!
RB: Umm...That was your intro
RB: Next up, the man who hangs out underneath Jared Padalecki's beautiful head of hair
Both: Jared Padalecki!
*WIld clapping and screaming from fans*
*moose kisses*
RS: So you had to wear a hat when we do a hair bit.
*Jared takes off hat*
RS: Thank you
RB: There it is!
*screaming increases*
*Jared puts hat back on*
*Immediately screams die*
RS: Give the people what they want man
*Takes hat off and fans start screaming again*
RS: Next up, a man who is living proof that sometimes
plastic surgery is undetectable in High-Def
JENSEN ACKLES!
*sounds of screams and ovaries exploding*
RS: He's a shy fellow
RB: Yeah, he's not comfortable in front of a lot of people
RS: Not a big crowd guy
RB: Next up,
*is cut off by Jensen waving at someone and making everyone else scream*
RB: Next up a person who's proven there's only room for
one trench coat wearing angel on network television
Both: IT'S MISHA COLLINS!!
*Wild banshee like screeching*
RB: You know, Rich
RS: Yes?
RB: Here's an interesting tidbit
*Dude yelling "MISHA YOUR FLIES UNDONE"*
RS: I think he said your flies open
*Jared laughs, Misha awkwardly zips up, Jensen makes the 'oh shit he fucked up face'*
RB: I-I don't speak fandom.
RS: *laughing* You don't speak scream?
RB: ADSJSKKIAHSKLADKDSILSJGHJSKID
*J2M laughing*
RS: Let me put that through the scream-eratior.
RS: Figure out-
RB: Uh Rich, here's an interesting tidbit.
This next actor, according to my cheat sheet
RB: We know he's the King of Hell but he's also
According to my cheat sheet, he's also A. Sheppard!
RS: OH! Well let's bring him out!
RS: It's Mark A. Sheppard!
*screaming in british*
*devilishly handsome bow*
RS: We are so-
*Mark points to Crowley Funko dolls*
RS: I know did you see that? It's amazing right?
JP: Do you have one? *laughs*
RB: And it's uncanny
*laughter from whole panel as they look at the dolls*
RB: You know what's weird though Mark? THe Funko doll, it's smiling a little too much
MS: WHAT HAPPENED TO YOURS?
JA: ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
RS: I don't know. Let's bring out our last guy
RS: I gotta be honest I'm super proud of this guy